[Music]
you could be anywhere in the world where
would it be back with my family where
are they in New York
how wonderful was this beautiful day
what was the best part of your day this
[Music]
if you could see the end of the world
where would you be
among the people I love I think that's
the only thing that counts whatever
you're going through
think about your happiest memory and
just keep going PS what was your
happiest memory getting married to my
lovely wife always remember that life is
all about having fun
I agree it is all about having fun and
that you should take every opportunity
to have fun sometimes we forget that
there are opportunities that have fun
but in everything that we do there's
being afraid of snakes is okay it gives
you a life don't let others steal your
joy being afraid keeps you alive that's
true I guess what's on your bucket list
do tomorrow
go to Japan
probably not home is wherever you are
with the ones who care about who do you
care about not really profound moments
start with simple thoughts the man or
the amount of negativity you're
presented with five minutes from now
could be your best moments I love that
cuz I just had some bad news today but
now I'm having a really great what do
you think about it that is very like
fortune cookies yeah don't let fear stop
you and what is your fear
Oh dad from
we're dying alone
no family or anyone else around you what
makes you happy
sunset at La Jolla Cove makes me happy
what is it that you seek I seek
happiness and a long life full of
adventure find Beauty and the little
things I think about my two kids
[Music]
but sup guys my name is Mariah and I'm
the owner of his channel I'm also the
person behind the camera I thought I'd
take a minute to thank all the
subscribers I came so far and maybe
asking you views to the subscribe button
if you liked this episode or if you're a
fan of my channel in general and yeah
into the subscribers that I have already
if you want to help grow my channel it
would mean a lot if you share in your
favorite episode the friend or two or
three or and help me gain more
subscribers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]